how we heal from the long-term
internalized effects of trauma and
abandonment
so if for example if in my childhood god
forbid if i was incested
if i was repeatedly beaten
if i was painfully abandoned
i was patient i was placed in this
really unbearable situation
that the very persons on whom i depended
to survive were the very people who were
destroying me
and therefore in order to survive it
i had to somehow
disconnect from the truth of what was
that because i couldn't bear it
and so it's because i disconnected from
the truth
that i live
and that might have been true when you
were a child
but the trouble is they get stuck in it
so
because i disconnect from the truth of
my life i live
if if i when i was being incest or
beaten i was passive
because if i would have spoke up it
would have been worse i could say to
myself because i was passive i lived
but then the person says no because i am
passive violence
because i'm
i'm i'm afraid just i'm afraid to step
forward on my own behalf i offer
external compliance so it's not to be
attacked or abandoned
and this survived this this survival
strategy formed in trauma i'm addicted
i'm addictively bonded to it because
even though i can tell i find it
embarrassing i find it difficult when i
try to break it i have strong
physiological reactions and it preempts
my ability to step forward can i be
vulnerable and safe at the same time
or because i got angry i live
no because i am angry i live a lot of
people in prison are stuck in that one
because they acted out
because i use food in a certain way or i
use sexuality in a certain way or when i
got older i compensated
for my inadequacies by by achieving
things like image over identity i live
no because i choose image over identity
i live and i can't stop
the bankruptcy is i can see it's not
working and i can't someone reaches out
for help
at a certain level one reaches out for
help concretizing the person who's there
for us and in whose presence we can
openly be this way who sees through it
and sees in us something of value we
can't yet see little by little we can
see it but when we turn to faith as a
resource this is the essence of our
faith really
is the essence of our faith
is that in our faith we could say and
for us as christians and jesus
we can say that the deepest question of
my life really
is not what my father thought of me
or my mother thought of me or my or what
my husband or wife thinks of me
or what my pastor my boss thinks of me
really the deepest issue isn't who i
what i think of me
but can i join god
and knowing who god knows me to be
can i join god in seeing who god sees me
to be when god sees me this is salvation
and in order to do this in order to do
this i have to let go
of my own present way of seeing things
and i discover i can't
we're afraid to lose the control that we
think that we have over the life that we
think that we're living and we're
addicted to what binds us
so out of the depths i cry unto thee
lord this is the cry for salvation can i
walk on water see can i is this possible
that i could place my life over into
your hands
and uh and so then the mystery of the
cross then
there's this mystery of this being
liberated from this deep addiction
to the to the illusion of an ultimately
isolated self they have to make it on
its own
to realize i'm in the presence of the
love that loves us and takes us to
itself
and uh through that through that inner
process of discipleship whatever we want
to call it we can come to apathea to
this true sobriety this deep sobriety
the peace of god that surpasses
understanding
and so this would be one way then of
understanding the spiritual dimensions
of the process of being freed from
addiction
from self-destructive internalized
patterns to open us up to this
relationship